[Music]
let's go to maria and tampa what's up
maria
hi
how are we doing
i am just so excited and very very
grateful yeah i'm excited thank you so
much for your time no i'm good grief
i'm so grateful for you you're too kind
so what's up
okay i am
super displeased with the way that i am
managing
my disordered eating and maintaining my
sobriety
hmm
walk me through it tell me more
so in the process of trying to frame up
my question neatly which is
kind of difficult
disorder eating and addiction are never
never uh
summed up neatly so give me the whole
messy mess
okay so i first of all am a mom i have
three kids five and under so i am in
just the best season of life
um this is true i am not being sarcastic
okay um
okay so i have racing thoughts it feels
like multiple trains of thoughts
zipping by in different directions super
fast super loud all the time in my head
and it all seems very urgent like
needs to be thought of right now
past present future
to-do list shame all of it at one time
all the time and i don't know how to
step out of that turn it down dismiss
the thoughts
um i also
uh
like i never
i had a really chaotic childhood and so
like the binge purge thing made a lot of
sense for
a while for me because it just was like
a semblance of control in my life
um but i
don't know how to take care of myself is
what it comes down to like i i do not
know how to relax so that i might enjoy
my body and my brain um and i'm just
like i'm not having a good time and
i'm gonna be bold and say i deserve to
be having a good time because
this is me this is literally exactly the
life that i've always wanted and i find
myself constantly dysregulated angry
agitated short tempered and therefore
everyone around me experiences that too
yep
god you mean
yeah
yeah i i don't i got more but no i know
you do
um
you're just incredible let me just say
that all right and
not enough people tell you that and i'm
grateful you you have an ability to
you've been to counseling before
yes in
attempts to
overcome what was just like a lot of
disconnection there you go my mom put me
in in treatment patients like
five times and it never for eating
because it wasn't the problem i also was
suicidal like i just needed like a hug i
think and
nobody knew that or like understood that
and so after
i moved out and like started living my
life with my like now husband i realized
i have a level of responsibility to
cultivate my mind and my body and my
lifestyle and so i am super informed but
i have
it is extremely
difficult for me to apply
any of the nerd things that i know a lot
about and i am so frustrated i'm so and
and i'm a
perfectionist and so i'm like
super full of shame
and guilt like all the time yeah um okay
the reason i asked if you've been in
counseling was
you have a
you're years down the road towards being
well and i know you don't realize that
your ability to see
from an elevated position both what's
going on and you're
putting some distance between your
response to what's going on and your
ability to point at all right here's
where it is and i don't i don't
i see i hear the the engine knocking
right here right your ability to do that
is
light years ahead of most people i talk
to good for you like i i want you to
know the work you've put in has not been
wasted okay
um
the word that keeps coming to mind as
you're talking is a it's a scary word
okay um for a couple of different
reasons but the word that keeps coming
to mind is
exhaustion
dude i have a four month old and a
two-year-old and a five-year-old and
they're all in my bed and
and and more than that
um your body's been in fight or flight
for about 30 years right yeah yeah and
so there's a point when you keep
adding in the quote-unquote right things
i crossed the finish line i got the life
i wanted you overcame so many odds
to get where you're
to achieve what you've achieved and to
cross the finish lines you've crossed
can we recognize that it's incredible
thank you for saying that the the the
professionals who were around you when
you were 14
would have looked at just an actuarial
table and said
this is probably not likely where you've
landed
and it's a testament to
strength and grit and you've probably
got chewed off broken fingernails
because you've scratched and clawed your
way to this point you had a picture in
your head and you will achieve this
is am i right
cracked and you found a guy tell me
about him is he awesome
he is awesome equally uh crazy but we
have
just we found each other
uh
like super young and have been together
ever since we've been together
for 10 years and we
you know like on paper i've done
everything the right way like we dated
for a few years and we were married for
a year and then we started having babies
and we're starting our own company and i
mean lots of really great things but um
he also
did not receive
i mean i guess just proper instruction
for living
love and just like basic things yeah so
we're just figuring it out together and
we kind of take turns being
the likes like i don't know more stable
one more mature one okay so just grow
together
so
you've done all the right stuff
the one
giant glaring omission
that i think is the hardest thing to do
is you have not
made peace with maria
and you have
run from what maria was
you've run from the hell that was your
childhood and you say chaotic i'm
calling bs on that you've had some
you've seen some stuff fair
yes sir okay
um
you
you haven't made peace with maria
and because you haven't made peace and i
i'm like i'm at you right imagine me and
you having chips and salsa right and
like you know i don't know if you're
sober but we're having a drink we're
hanging out okay your husband's hanging
out and we're just chilling so i'm not
i'm not getting on to you i'm just
telling you
until you let maria
go
maria nine years old maria 14 years old
maria 4 is still fighting on your behalf
because there's still a mom that no
matter what the hell you do you cannot
make her get off your back
and then she tries to solve it by
sending you away from her right
am i on to it you still there
yeah yeah
am i right tell me i'm wrong
no you're so right she just like it
feels bad because i know no no no don't
defend her she's right no excuses yeah
she's a grown-up she's a grown-up you
don't have to defend her right now yeah
she didn't know though that's okay
but it doesn't minimize the hurt
right so true yeah no it still hurts
what about dad where was dad
well they got a divorce when i was three
they co-parent no not well we saw him
about every other weekend and then
um because my brother and i are close in
age and then
when i was probably 12 my brother moved
out to live with him and i pretty much
stopped all contact like that he stopped
talking i stopped talking to him we
never saw each other until i had my
first kid that was like five years ago
so
it's never and there's a 3 to 12 year
old maria
continuing to continuing to ask herself
what could i have done differently to
keep this thing together
how could i have acted a little bit
different so that dad would come around
a little bit more
and then they took your lifeline away
which is your brother
and then at 12 years old you found
yourself responsible for mom's
emotional stability
fair
yeah
if i say this mom flies off the handle
so i need to make sure that i don't say
this i don't eat this i don't do this i
need to clamp down on everything i can
control because if i don't mom fill in
the blank fair
yeah
that's an exhausted nine-year-old little
girl
and so running from and again can i tell
you i do
my my family situation is different but
the sprinting and i recognize this in
the mirror okay so i feel like i'm
talking to myself here
i sprinted so hard to show with my
income and my job title and the
university i worked for and my two
healthy little kids and my pretty wife
that i could get all the stuff
and my body was still
swinging and kicking and running and
hiding
as it had been since i was little little
little
and so the work now is less perfection
and he this stuff gets more
sophisticated
and so as you have you started have you
started binging again
um i
binge i find that it's like yes but not
as frequently by any means but it's like
when i'm particularly tired particularly
frustrated
um
like i
am just in the middle of all of these
kids and everybody's screaming and
instead of screaming or like wanting to
drink i might just go eat a whole box of
nutty bars and pop-tarts and a bag of
stomach uh
gummy sour gummy worms oh my gosh you
just you just said all my things yes
they are my favorite and i can't have
them in the house because it's like
what is self-control is that a thing
listen
i was i was on the phone with my doctor
again this weekend dr vickery i think
he's one of the greatest doctors in the
united states of america and he told me
as a reminder he saw my blood work and
i've got it out of the house for x
number of months now
and he said
i have never like i my triglycerides
have dropped my my all sorts of metrics
i don't want to geek out but he said as
a reminder you can't have these in your
house based on your genetic profile
right so but let's back out so yes
you're right it just is and it stinks
and i hate it and that's that's that's
the cards we've been dealt right um
some people look like brad pitt some
people look like me right and that's
just the cards i got dealt and so i just
have to know
um
but let's back out for a second
can we get real graphic is that cool
yeah please like all the yes when you
throw up
and your stomach rolls it's rolling over
that hill
and you get to the point where it starts
taking on it it starts doing it itself
and your
core tightens up a lot and then it
relaxes and tightens up relaxes and your
tears come because just because it's
your body working so hard
there is a complete and total
when that's over right a release
am i right
yes yeah
that's your body
at your head in your mind
trying to find ways that it can go
whoosh
like why not just go take a walk like
how come i cannot
like because
your body's at war
your body's a war
and as when's what age were you when the
first time
well i won't pre i'm pretty sure i'm
right
what was the age somebody hurt you
i cannot remember okay
before 12 or after 12 or both
before and after but i subjected myself
after as a teenager nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope
no if i would have just said those words
to my own kid like that would have been
the most messed up thing like i did not
subject myself to anything
i was taken advantage of and it's not
supervised that's right
and
you're continuing to continuing to tell
14 year old maria 17 year old maria who
was desperate for someone to look at her
and say you're worthy even for 30
minutes
you're desperate for somebody to say no
you're worth you're worth being around
on my terms but you're worth being
around right do you see what i'm saying
here's what i'm trying to i'm just
trying to draw a thread here
to an
incredible mother
and a woman of strength you have no idea
how strong you are
the amount of energy you and your body
put forth every day to hold back the
tsunami
is
something that most of us walking
through life have absolutely no idea
and the greatest gift you can give
yourself is to put your arms down and
let the water run
because it'll drain out
and your body will no sleep and your
body will know intentionality and then
you'll have actual
you'll have strength for willpower and
this is all
neuroscientist isn't just like woo-woo
like
[Music]
like like literally what do i do to do
that i am
here's what you got to do you've got to
go enter into a therapeutic relationship
with somebody with one goal in mind
not to stop a behavior
but to make peace with maria
keep these words in your mind you have
to let that little girl go play
and right now she's fighting off an
uncle she's fighting off
your brother's friends she's fighting
off high school she's fighting off mom
she's fighting off
dad what was it about me
why'd y'all take my brother from me
and then all of the decisions that you
make right the the the the band-aids
that we use
drink this sleep with him
do this
snort that all of those things are
a brain saying somebody freaking connect
with me
and now you're a mother with a beautiful
family by the way you're in the middle
of a blender you know that right
yeah and that's like i want to enjoy it
and i want them to enjoy it and your
brains get got increasingly
sophisticated modes of trying to take
care of you
when you were a kid it was
behavior a and action b and action c
now your brain is going to just run and
run and run and run trying to get your
attention
and occasionally it will build up and
build up and build up like an itch you
can't scratch until you just eat
everything and then throw up and get
that complete and utter
and then you can start building it back
up again
you have to have to have to do two
things you got to go get into
a therapeutic relationship you gotta
call somebody
okay and let them know i've built it
back i'm
i'll storm the gates of hell with my
strength i'm strong
and i'm ready to heal
the second thing you're gonna have to do
which my guess is you don't have is
you're gonna have to get a couple of
women in your life that you trust that
become your friends have you ever done
that
no
my guess is you are lonely lonely lonely
and you have the picture of everything
that looks good but your body is
screaming where are my friends
yes
that's here
okay those two things
please are you hearing me that i tell
you how what
just
great aba you are you get that
i hear you it's really impressive
they'll work forward now like we have to
talk to some people like in in the gym
um who work out too much like
professional athletes who work out too
hard
is i'm gonna have to train you i'm gonna
teach you how to rest how to back it
down that's where you are
is yes so that's like a therapist that's
exactly right
and you have to be willing to do
hard now
that sounds so mean i know maria you're
gonna have to be willing to
walk through some old memories that
you've your body's protecting you from
you're gonna have to walk through some
real anger towards your dad and some
real anger towards your mom even though
you love them
you're gonna have to walk through some
real
forgiveness and peace for your 14 15 17
22 25 year old self
because that beautiful little girl was
just trying to find connection and i
don't i don't blame her for a second
she's a kid
and you're gonna have to
come to terms own if you will you're
gonna have to own what happened when
you're a little little girl because that
crap shouldn't happen either
you are brave and strong and you've done
all this work leading up to right now
and now is when you jump off the deep
end with the help of a professional and
we're gonna go get well in about six
months and about nine months i want you
to call me back
cause my guess is you're gonna put on
about four or five pounds of muscle
you're gonna smile and you're gonna be
laughing and you're gonna be saying oh
my because you still got three kids
under five
but it's gonna be different air that
you're breathing i'm so so proud of you
hang on the line i'm going to send you a
copy of on your past change your future
i want you to read it and internalize it
even take it to the therapist with you
and say it's time